you've spoken a lot and about empathy
and it's impossible for me not to
mention we've actually had almost two
weeks of shows I believe now where we've
not once mentioned the president I'd
stay tie I haven't wanted him to be a
part of the conversation I've wanted the
conversation to go deeper than that but
I'll bring him up now because we have a
leader of the country who I think
everyone would agree has a chronic
inability to demonstrate empathy and III
I feel that that has been a situation
like what happened after the killing of
George Floyd is as crazy as it sounds
it's an opportunity for change it's an
opportunity for the president to bring
us all together and to say beautiful
things that might actually bring about
lasting change and I feel that that has
been squandered in but by our president
you know I love you for not centering
him in your conversations because it's
not it's not about him this election is
coming up is not a referendum on one guy
in one office it's really referendum on
who we are and who we're gonna be to
each other and we've got to raise the
frequency in our nation in terms of the
love and empathy but you mention him so
let me just say this
I just fundamentally believe and I've
watched leaders on both sides of the
aisle demonstrate this you can't lead
the people if you don't love the people
and and he just does not love all
America you don't agree with all
Americans but he is his willingness to
so cavalierly deny so many Americans
human dignity for him to trample upon
the the the the very humanity of other
Americans to cheapen this nation by
working so hard to divide us and to make
us hate each other all of those things
mean he is illegitimate in the kind of
moral leadership that we need he may
have the trappings of power he may have
the title of the office but the the
title doesn't make the man the man
to make the title he has been a failure
a failure in a moral audio off estat
Republicans from Lincoln to Democrats
like Obama who have led with love for
their country with malice towards none
with charity towards all he's had so
much malice towards so many and so
little charity towards others so I want
this to be a moral moment in America and
I'm so proud of his cap former cabinet
members and national Republicans who are
coming forward and saying just that that
this man is uniquely unqualified for
this moment in history and he is
cheapened to me the the greatest ideal
in all of humanity which America has
stripped Straus has striven in every
generation to make manifest in this
world is that we are a nation of love
where we love one another he is so
failed to be in the fight to make us a
more loving nation or as king would say
a more beloved community and I am I am I
have so so much hurt for what he's done
to people and I've watched it I've
watched people we call some countries
[ __ ] countries I've seen people
immigrants come to me begging me to do
something about it I've watched him
degrade you know I talked to a college
friend of mine whose kid was in the ED
lock-in at Lafayette in Lafayette Park
when he stormed in had people storm in
with with rubber bullets and tear gas
and the anguish that somebody would
think in this sacred capital where
people from the march on Washington to
second Amendment rights people have come
for generations to peacefully petition
their government and he just tramples
that for what a national security issue
because he had to urgently get someone
Knope to hold up a book that he should
read that talks about humility and the
meek so I I can't give him more of my
energy I want to give it to to us I want
to give it to love I want to give it to
good people who right now don't
understand the urgency for them to act
that's where I want to give it and so I
don't want to he's not the center of my
concern and and I appreciate you live
having a show that reflects that well I
you know I have not wanted to do
Trump jokes or make it all about Donald
Trump because ultimately I find him very
uninteresting and and and his action
saddened me but I I'm angry I reserved
my anger for people that enable him
that's what makes me angry and I get
very angry at people who do know better
who are in a party that maybe in the
short term benefiting from the fact that
he holds that office but in the long
term I don't know how they're gonna be
able to talk to their kids or their
grandchildren and so I've been very
moved by especially the military
leadership that's come forward
madis Kelley most recently : Powell that
is something that the Republican Party
does show respect for is our military
leadership and when you have these
prominent members of the military
speaking out that my heart swells with
pride and I'm very happy that that that
people are coming forward I just wish
there were more I wish there were more
people who would step forward and say
you know what yes we got some good court
appointments yes we got some stuff done
because we had someone in the Oval
Office who would do our bidding but this
is too much you know I wish we'd hear
from from from more politicians like
that well we've heard the throughout
history the bystander King talked about
we have to repent in our day and age not
for the simply for the vitriolic words
and violent actions of the bad people
but the silence in action and the good
people so I think I think that you're
right and I think that this again is
that moment in American history
and I actually feel sorry for the
Republican Party because there's a lot
of his primary opponents but in 2016 15
and 16 said they predicted Lindsey
Graham all of them predicted he would
destroy the Republican Party and a lot
of them have gone silent now and are
refusing to tell the truth of the
perverse
the meanness that he's Cavalier in the
meanness that isn't it the heart of a
lot of Republicans you name some of them
like Colin Powell and so this is
ultimately a test and a test isn't over
this is a president who could disrespect
a peaceful transition of power in a
hundred and fifty days if he lose he's
already trying to be legitimize the
election this is a president is capable
has shown us he's capable of anything
and so the stress test on this nation
over the next hundred and fifty hundred
and sixty days are gonna be great and
and this is a defining moment for all of
us and in a defining moment you're not
defined by what happens to you this
guy's capable of anything
you were always defined by how you
choose to respond and I agree with you
I'm happy for those who have decided to
respond by not silence but by speaking
up by lifting their voices to be heard
by history